Emily Blunt is starring in one of the
summer's biggest movies — and after that,
she's taking a break for a while. Here's why.
The British actress revealed, in conversation
with Bruce Bozzi on his podcast "Table for Two,"
that she's set to take some time away
from acting now that her latest movie,
"Oppenheimer," is set to release soon.
Blunt appears in Christopher Nolan's
latest epic as Katherine Oppenheimer, wife
to Cillian Murphy's J. Robert Oppenheimer,
and apparently, that'll be her
last role for the next year.
Blunt has two daughters — 7-year-old
Violet and 9-year-old Hazel — with her
husband John Krasinski, and as she told Bozzi,
she wants to enjoy their childhood more fully.
"This year, I'm not working. I worked quite
a bit last year and my oldest baby is nine,
so we're in the last year of single
digits. And I just feel [like] there
are cornerstones to their day that
are so important when they're little.
She continued,
"And it's, 'Will you wake me up?
Will you take me to school? Will
you pick me up? Will you put me to
bed?' And I just need to be there."
Ultimately, Blunt said she feels guilty about
potentially missing her daughters' childhoods,
and she thinks that's common for
moms. She added on the podcast,
"I think maybe all mothers are. You're
just prone to feeling bad for, God forbid,
wanting something outside of being a mother."
Blunt was clear about wanting
to take time away from acting
so she could spend more time with her
daughters — and it definitely doesn't
seem like she wants them to follow her
lead and become actors themselves. In a
June interview with Harper's Bazaar UK ahead of
the release of "Oppenheimer," Blunt revealed,
"My toes curl when people tell me, 'My daughter
wants to be an actress.' I want to say,
'don't do it!' Because it's a hard industry and
it can be very disappointing. A lot of people
tell you not to take things personally –
but it's completely personal, especially
when you're being judged on how you look. So
you just have to endure that side of things."
It's clear that Blunt, like many women in
the public eye trying to balance successful
careers and parenthood, is frustrated by
the notion that you can't "have it all."
Even though she's unequivocal
about this break from acting,
she's also as ambitious as ever.
Acknowledging to Harper's Bazaar
that she's pleased that equal pay has become
a bigger discussion in Hollywood, Blunt said,
"Ambition is healthy – it shouldn't be seen
as a negative thing. It's about knowing your
worth and what you bring to a project,
and never apologizing for doing well."
When all is said and done, it seems fair to
say that Blunt deserves a break considering
just how many projects she's filmed lately. She
stars in the Amazon miniseries "The English,"
and beyond "Oppenheimer," Blunt has several
major movies already banked; later in 2023,
her film "Pain Hustlers," which tells the dark
story of the modern pharmaceutical industry,
arrives in theaters. Her action
thriller alongside Ryan Gosling,
David Leitch's "The Fall Guy," is set to release
in 2024, with Blunt playing the ex-girlfriend to
Gosling's stuntman who's trying to direct her own
film within the film. She's also reuniting with
Krasinski for the ensemble comedy "IF," which is
slated for a spring 2024 release and features a
packed cast including Fiona Shaw, Bobby Moynihan,
Steve Carell, Phoebe Waller-Bridge, and more.
Speaking of Krasinski, there are always
whisperings about a third "Quiet Place"
movie — and Blunt has starred in both of the
films. A spin-off prequel starring Lupita Nyong'o,
"A Quiet Place: Day One," is on the way,
but as far as the mainline franchise goes,
nothing's been announced yet. For now, though,
Blunt has more than earned her time away from
acting — though audiences will undoubtedly
be happy whenever she chooses to return.